all right so let's be honest here how
many of you guys actually care about
Java and Scala Oh bigger turnout all
right
usually it's all Python Python okay so
why end e4j so why do we need another
scientific computing library there's a
lot of them right you know so there's
there's fifteen different standards I'm
inventing the sixteenth wait wait a
minute no no okay so what what why did
why did I do this
so the JVM unlike awesome Python is very
fragmented you know so if you think
about it there's all sorts of libraries
there's J Blas there's breeze there's
spire there's coordinate there's core
matrix NAT live blasts there's all sorts
of matrix libraries on the JVM they all
do different things so some better than
others
like net live blast for example great
library abstracts away a lot of your
common concerns you know it works with
native and GPU and whatever else you
know but doesn't have tensors breeze has
tensors but not numpy syntax you know so
the goal was to provide a common
abstraction and DSL for the JVM that
works like numpy so if you guys actually
have to work on a Hadoop and spark
cluster you know cuz like eventually
some of you guys might be interested in
learning that then you know you you want
it to know you want the experience to
not suck so my background is pipe you
know a lot of I taught a lot of Python
students and I found that I liked I you
know as a Java programmer I liked Python
a lot better for specifically scientific
computing it was a pleasure I also did a
lot of MATLAB as well so I come from
this background where it's like you know
this needs to exist but it doesn't but
you know the good languages aren't
production izybelle or they aren't part
of the production stack so the general
idea here is that you know like you know
you've heard about who do big data
spark Java Scala you've heard about the
scale and all that other fun stuff you
know the JVM you know most optimized
platform out there for garbage that's
garbage collected it's been around for
20 years and as a killer app for most
things but unfortunately it it nobody
nobody's ever figured out like how to
write I'll get libraries for because the
language is clunky I as a Java
programmer hate the Java language itself
I'm a big advocate for Scala though so a
lot of the a lot of the a scale
computing I think needs a good library
so what I'm gonna cover tonight are a
lot of the underlying concepts of
scientific libraries so for those of you
who do a lot of you know MATLAB and
Python and are and whatever else you
guys will get you guys will learn
something about the system side of the
scientific languages and then I'll kind
of cover a lot of the different
components of nd 4j and you can kind of
see this as more of less a conceptual
abstraction of what does a scientific
library look like what is it made of and
then from there I'll kind of explain
like how everything fits together and
what do you do with this and then what I
want to do is compare it to MATLAB numpy
and all the other associated libraries
so alright so first of all blas in India
race what is blas so Blas stands for
basic linear algebra subprograms
whenever you hear about quote unquote
fast matrix routines from Andrew Aang's
machine learning class that's Blas so
blast is a set of routines that are
highly optimized for linear algebra so
usually so in this case blast is focused
on dense matrices though so dense is not
sparse sparse has lots of zeros right so
blast is highly optimized for dense
operations so this includes things like
matrix multiplication this could be the
axpy operation ax B operation is a great
example that it's it's an alpha times X
plus y so what do you do with that you
can do addition with that you can do
subtraction and it's all linear so again
highly optimized and it combines up it
combines common operations that you
would normally never they would never
really never think about yourself you
know you don't want to deal with
stuff so blast blast deals with weirder
linear buffers so every under every
underlying implementation of every nd
array whether it's MATLAB numpy or any
of these other scientific environments
all work off a border call what's called
a linear buffer a linear buffer is just
a list of numbers literally that's all
it is it's a list of numbers and then nd
arrays are built on top of these buffers
and what they do is they index into
these buffers via stripes so Strides is
like okay what is the stride to what is
how many elements do we need to move in
the buffer to get to the next row you
can use this as a baseline you can use
this strides as a baseline to actually
build tensors you can build 66 and 70
arrays whatever you you can get as crazy
with it as you want so and then the
other the other concept here is then
this idea of an axis so an axis is wrote
thing if we just think in terms of 2d
rows and columns another way to describe
this would be you know if we had a
tensor you know let's just say a 3d
image you have three channels red green
and blue so if I have a 28 by 28 image
the the tensor is actually made up of
three 28 by 28 matrices each 28 by 28
matrix represents a particular part of
the channel you have a red matrix of
green matrix and a blue matrix so when
you're working with images you know even
in like Photoshop what you're actually
doing is you're doing a lot of your
you're doing a lot of signal processing
and all sorts of crazy math and it's
actually on tensors but you know if you
want to if you want to get it down to
like 2d space you grayscale it so it's a
great example those are all mathematical
operations that you can do with all
these scientific libraries so this
underpins every and every anything to do
with coding and engineering and math is
and D arrays and Blas so what does this
look like exactly so this is MATLAB so
you know we have a standard set of
conventions right you have a variable
and then you say one's you know maybe a
random maybe you have give me a give me
a matrix that that's all zeroes of shape
two by five so a shape in this case is
just
a simple 2d example is rows and columns
you'll notice then that I say some a and
one what does that mean that means along
the first axis in this case in um in
this case in MATLAB everything's ones
based right so give me the elements the
sum of the elements along the first
dimension or row row or column sum and
then give me the answer
so if you add up if you add up all the
elements row wise you get you get five
fives right so nice and simple so here's
a numpy so lots of commonalities here so
you'll notice numpy dot ones so the only
difference here is I have to import
numpy so numpy is bolted on to python
basically so it's been around for a long
time and it's the standard in scientific
computing you know where you have like
julia for example julia again
everything's built in you know like
default operations like ones random R
and n binomial sampling a lot of the
things that you would do in math are all
already built into the language numpy is
a library that uses blas internees for
compute for computing all these matrices
and stuff
right so so you'll know other than that
it looks it looks really similar though
so you have ones random whatever julia
same thing so what is it look at this
look like in Java and Scala so this is
this is a code snippet from nd for J so
this is Scala so Scala works you know
just you know in your cluster you know
so that's kind of the idea so typically
in data science you have you you you do
all your export trade analysis in Python
maybe you a pandas maybe you may but
either way you're gonna be you're gonna
be sub sampling that data maybe you're
building your models with scikit-learn
that kind of stuff right you know I
don't want to do that anymore I want to
just I don't want to rewrite my
algorithms so being a Java and Scala guy
I was like well why shouldn't this exist
why doesn't this exists already
you know so I wanted I wanted the same
syntax from the lineage of numpy in
MATLAB
something that looks respectable
encourages vectorize thinking so
data scientists are always thinking in
terms of vectors vectorization some
along the first axis right it's highly
fast don't use for loops Java they're
like used for loops all the time right
you know that's not scalable and in this
case I wanted something highly optimized
for the JVM so what I did was I said
okay let me give myself an abstraction
that works over every every different
Java library you know maybe there's
another faster Java library that comes
out so the problem with Java is
fragmentation
it's a terrible language it's fast but
stodgy it's old and everybody has an
opinion about how to do something so
what I wanted to do is create a library
that I could write my own algorithms
against in this case I created it for D
pointing for J that's my that's that's
my core creation so I created I create
it for this for the sake of D pointing
for J though so nd for J exists as an
abstraction over all the different kinds
of platforms that you can that you can
do computation on so here are some of
the different blast implementations so
there's Q blasts cube loss is Rothsay so
this is this is by Nvidia so you know
you have their own proprietary cuda
language you have open blas so there's
you you're gonna see what atlas and
little pack as well
all those are open source blast
implementations there's a lot of them so
the primary the primary website for this
is net live gorg na t l ib org that
contains all the reference blas
implementations and that also contains
the by far the best documentation for
the overall spec right so other than
that there's also envy Blas there's CI
Blas so CI boss is by Nvidia or AMD
sorry and it uses something called open
CL so open CL is a set of standards that
every GPU vendor implements GPUs are
highly optimized for for scientific
computing right they have thousands of
cores thousands so every time you render
something on your on your phone on your
monitor it's using a GPU so the problem
is GPUs are hard to program against you
know like you know gpgpu came
you know you know quite a while back now
but you know it's still it's still
clunky you you still have to take data
from the CPU copy it to the GPU you have
to treat the GPU almost like a server or
something you connect you on the
internet even though it's on your
computer you upload data to it you run
some computations on your beta matrix
and then you still have to get the data
back down so it's almost like you have a
network on your local laptop why the
heck should I have to do that anyways
it's hard it's brittle and it's
error-prone and the programming model is
completely different so what I also
wanted to do with Indy for J was getting
a set of transparent and easily
recognizable CUDA kernels that worked
under the same abstraction so I wanted
to treat blas as what it should be a
standard I wanted to treat it as oh I
want to do XP I want to do multiple
matrix multiply I don't want have to
think about well which should I use
what's the hardware all I want to do is
just you use it on my cluster and then I
can just ask what's available and then
in this case like the implication here
is my machine learning algorithms will
deploy in your cluster as well as your
phone so the idea like why I didn't just
write something against ml ed for
example great libraries it is you know
you can't you can't run ml Lebon you
can't run an ml event a phone the idea
was to have a common abstraction that
would work on Android or on the or on
the phone so you could you could run all
your models locally with sike it like
kind of like scikit-learn but then
deploy it to your cluster without
rewriting your code cross-platform was
the overall idea here so if you so I
only showed you Scala code but Java
looks exactly the same it's just instead
of Val you have nd array you have int
array same idea so why did I write it in
Java instead of skyline I know closure
exists you know I like Scala as a
personally like Scala
I don't like Lisp so I chose not to do I
chose not to do closure myself but I
wanted to give people the option to so
I'm most experienced in in Java so
that's kind of what I did
there's my bias though but I did it also
for the reason of Interop all right OOP
okay so the general idea is you have one
library that's a domain-specific
language a domain-specific language is
just a language you speak you know it's
just that and then it's it's usually a
set of rules right
so nd for J in this case is a DSL for
any matrix computing library on the JVM
so there's lots of them
there's breeze net live again I want a
one common I wanted one common standard
that I could program against that would
work transparently on CUDA or on the CPU
so in this case you know each each each
library has its own merits and I don't
want to have to think about which one I
don't want to think about which one to
use so it's it's literally just it's an
abstraction layer you have a back-end
and then those backends are composable
you can and all you have to do rather
than compiling like you do a native code
you only have a jar file all right so
sorry just making sure I didn't go over
time so core idea everything everything
in Indy for J's composable these are
just the core components of a scientific
library so add a tab up ER so if you
remember that buffer object I mentioned
earlier you know it's just a list of
numbers but it's basically I want an
abstraction over that though I don't
want to care about how the data is
stored the data buffer could be a
distributed it could be distributed so
you can have shards and all this other
fancy you like distribute systems terms
or it could be on your GPU it could just
be a pointer so in this case like a
great example this is Jake CUDA so I
actually have a Jake CUDA data buffer
that sits on top of the GPU and
allocates memory freeze it and it's
basically it's basically a proxy for a
handle and then I don't have to think
about C anymore where it's like size of
the length and all this other Oh free a
lot like I don't have to think about
that I can just think of in terms of a
buffer that I create and I destroy nice
and simple so what I'm strexy away the
idea of memory data buffers have a
length that's it they have a length and
a way to get input elements nice and
simple f of T's so signal processing is
one of the most computationally
intensive algorithms out there so in
this case what I want to do is then give
myself an abstraction where if there's
an F of T if there's some 15
holman tation out there that I want to
use I can so where does this come in
primarily primarily in a lot of deep
learning applications for me
specifically you know signal processing
is very very computationally intensive
very slow so I wanted to give myself the
ability to swap in implementations of
FFTs the same as applicable for
convolutions as well convolutions
typically work on images so a
convolution for those of you who don't
know is just a way of superimposing two
images on each other that's all they do
it's basically it's basically a really
fancy multiplication operation so but
again really slow
another thing matrix libraries have are
complex numbers so no one likes dealing
with the imaginary world well you know
but everybody you know every library has
a so I wanted to give myself an
instruction for complex numbers as well
so this primarily comes up in fast
Fourier transforms a blast wrapper so
block trapper is again just a way to
access whatever blessed implementation I
have on my class path so Java and Java
and Scala just have this idea of a class
path which is just the the current files
that are that are that are present on
like what I have access to more or less
then and then for those for those of you
who know Theano
the idea of an OP an OP is just an
operation I'm a dot product some
element-wise operations it's all like
it's all there it's just an idea of
transforming a matrix there's different
kinds of ops accumulators in GPU and
called reducers right and then you have
Illinois's operations where you have an
X Y and an X of Y and a Z the axpy
operation is a great example of that
where you have you have your X Y or Y so
X so a times X plus y is equal to Z
right so Z is your result so I wanted to
take a lot of these common abstractions
and put them all in one place how much
time do I have left just be honest with
me here 10 minutes ok cool all right
so so what I wanted to do was I wanted
to make every scientific library
swappable I didn't care what it was so
what I wanted to do was create my own my
own abstraction that I could just
delegate to write my algorithms against
but then I could I could actually mix
and match different kinds of backends
so a back-end is just a way of doing
computation it could be mixed GPU and
CPU it could be like maybe maybe I want
to take the the CUDA F of T and the the
seat the Intel MKL blast whatever I
don't care the core here is that you
want to you want to have scientific
primitives and you want to have them an
abstraction over all those parameters so
I want to think and I want to think
conceptually not not not at the low
level so these are these are things that
engineers typically do themselves you
know like an engineer is able to
implement these things but I don't want
to like I don't want to have to do that
though like I just I want to think in
terms of primitives this gives the
ability of scientists to just think
about oh I want to do fast Fourier
transform I want to know it's fast
oh this implementations now the other
thing is this implementation is too slow
this new cool thing just came out I want
to try it out well implement it back end
and you don't have to rewrite all your
code right so again just to reiterate
numpy MATLAB and all these other guys
there is no fragmentation they are the
dominant platform they have then and
everybody interrupts and it just works
this is a problem in the JVM ecosystem
so the JVM ecosystem is very you know
despite you know despite the language
being fast and whatever else it's
fragmented it's so it's it's terrible
it's terrible to write programs for
especially when you get in a three and
forty I again like three and forty is
highly specialized to images and signal
processing but again like for those of
you who want to be up the ability to do
it it should be there even if you only
deal with like rows and columns yourself
so a lot of the so the other problem is
like a lot of the a lot of the current
matrix libraries a lot of the current
matrix libraries only only think about
2d that's what that's that's been most
of the problems tensors are actually
starting to become more common in matrix
factorization in a lot of other kinds of
applications recommenders so so tensors
are becoming more and more relevant over
time so the ability to do the ability
the ability to do 3d and then on top of
that being able to do it in a
distributed setting and then being able
to write your code against one standard
rather than like 20 hopes a lot you know
cuz like it makes you more productive as
a software engineer
so the other thing I wanted to do was
for once and for all bring vectorize
thinking to the JVM
so the JVM is the JVM for scientific
computing is slow unless you do unless
you have some sort of native bindings or
j'ni and Java native interface for those
you don't know but you know I don't want
it to think about Jan I either like
there's plenty there's actually plenty
of libraries out there for AMD Intel
like every chip maker puts out their own
blast implementation their own like
crazy like crazy fast like math routines
you know which is awesome but you know
all they're trying to do is get you on
there get you get get walk-in they're
trying to get you on their system like
come over here we got this really fast
stuff like it's great right you know my
goal is to say well yeah that's cool but
you know like I'll just implement like
your standard or whatever and then I'll
just use it my code and I don't have to
rewrite it reduce lock in all right so
other than that for those of you who
know ml a little more I do most of my
stuff is neural network so I have to
think in terms of objective or loss
functions uh convex solvers so gradient
descent for those of you who don't for
for those of you who know what it what
that is I'm not gonna explain ml tonight
but if you know what it is it's there
adaptive learning rates so the so I had
to I had to implement I had to implement
like 10 different configurations of Atta
grad so I wanted to put all that and one
object I didn't really fit anywhere else
so there it's and also random number
generators so everybody wants their own
custom random number generator I don't
know why but everybody has their own
custom implementation so in this case
like what I wanted the ability to do was
implement a random number generator for
the GPU as well as the CPU so if I want
to generate random numbers on the GPU
this gives me the ability to do that if
I want to set a seed I just say to say
get random set seed if I want if I want
my probability distributions there's
also distributions object so I can say
nd for Jade I get distributions dot
binomial dot normal dot uniform whatever
you want to do right the whole idea here
is that you'll notice these are all
common patterns we see over and over
again on every scientific platform so
again I want to be able to think in
terms of those primitives
and I don't want it to think about your
specific implementation so regardless of
whether you guys use it or not I wrote
it for myself and if if you get anything
else on this presentation it's that oh
this is what a scientific library is
made of these are like the components
not a lot of people distill it down to
these are the components of a scientific
library so again I just want to I just
want to reiterate the ability to run on
Windows is something not most deep
learning platforms can do all of them
rely on CUDA or some like some sort of C
blob so I wanted to take advantage of
Java's cross-platform nature so I wanted
to be able to deploy it on Windows or on
your Android phone or scale it up to a
cluster Java is the only one where you
can actually like do all three and and
do it relatively easily you know it's
not gonna work you know it's not it's
not embedded systems right I'm not
trying to go there you know I'm trying
to I'm trying to I'm trying to go to
where the users are and we're like and
just you know have the most coverage
basic idea there so in this case that's
a lot like linux skills skills up to
your cluster and then it can also work
on your phone alright that's it thank
you
I'll take questions if there's any real
quick two minutes
well okay so I supported I supported
kuda 7 within two days of it coming out
brie still has experimental experimental
kuda support and they aren't actually
trying to implement multi-threaded easy
GPU access so they're so what I'm trying
to do is I'm trying my customers require
insane amounts of skill because they're
all they're all hardware makers so they
work so it's all sensor data real-time
video like 30 frames per second and real
streaming right so I want the ability to
do to mix spark streaming and CUDA and I
want that to be fast and low latency so
I want I want I want I want the ability
to bring out the potential and I don't
want it to rely on somebody else to do
it um so I have extreme requirements
relative to the rusting industry but you
know a nd for J is kind of my way of
reaching out to the rest of the
community being like this thing's here
I could have breezes a back end for an
example you know cuz like I think of
Indy for J's a DSL I don't think of it
as a like it's not a hard core matrix
library it's it's a DSL thanks um if you
look at my github probably not uh no
it's um no I I don't really know because
each back-end is optimized for every
platform so until I'm K so if you
include an until I'm KL a well it will
run raw x86 if you include CUDA it will
run on it will run only on the GPU right
yeah so I want I want I want I want I
want if you if you have if you have 20
CUDA boxes I want you to be able to run
spark on those right so I want that to
be easy to do and not error-prone so I
want I want integrations to be I want
integrations to be a first-class citizen
as well as like you know there's always
gonna be some latency if you're using
any garbage-collected language
whatsoever in existence anything that's
not see basically maybe rust some some
years down the road you know like you're
not gonna like you're not you're not
gonna do that kind of programming on the
JVM like it's the JVM still fast enough
for most applications and if it's not
fast enough throw more hardware at it so
I'm targeting a different market than
the embedded theme be embedded people
Thanks
um honestly like okay so to be frank
with you a lot of the deal for J
ecosystem is still very early right so
test like the api's baits now I'm pretty
happy with the architecture but at the
end of the day like it's still in it so
it's an open source project I'm I'm
writing most of it myself you know
because you know not a lot of people
write deporting libraries in this kind
of stuff
so honestly like at least bug covered
like bug coverage helps a lot you know
just you know like pull requests
occasionally if you happen to come up
come across something that you were you
weren't doing like I interact with my
users all in real time usually I'm
always on Gator I'm always on IRC like
you know cuz like my documentation sucks
I'll be honest with you I'm aware of
that and so I'm trying to like I'm
trying you know I'm trying to get so
documentation as well right so like if
you ask me how something works and then
you can write up a tutorial like great
the PM of the day like I'm trying to I'm
trying to bootstrap I'm trying to
bootstrap my own interpretation of ML
I'll say this or the only commercially
backed pure open-source deep learning
I'm also writing The O'Reilly book on it
called deporting forge a deal for Jam
beyond so that'll be that'll be due out
to summer so I'm committed to teaching
people and I'm committed I'm committed
to making sure that you can solve
problems so if you can you can help me
I'll pull requests issues complaint like
complaint at me to say this sucks like I
love I love actual critical feedback I'm
not gonna like I'm not gonna yell back
at you I'm not delusional so if I can
learn something from you awesome
so we have okay so we have word Tyvek on
spark which by default means it'll work
on CUDA to some of these other things I
also have I also have just a normal like
multi-threaded implementation both both
interrupts that both both of those
Interop and export very easily we said
unlike unlike unlike every unlike so
we're actually compatible with the gens
implementation so we have negative
sampling we have we primarily use
hierarchical softmax but so all that's
there I have I have experimental at
ogród support in there as well so oh so
a lot of things it's there on the the
word connect is the Lord the Vectis the
the word effect is multi-threaded but
slower than I like which is why I give
you Bill give the ability to import the
see vectors as well but yeah it's it's
there if you want it yeah so oh by the
way so I'm also going to implement
MapReduce base because like the problem
with every so the only other at scale
implementation is the e I'm the loop
version but it has problems with memory
you you go look at the milling list if
you don't believe me I'm trying I'm very
conscious of that as well so I'm trying
to I I do a lot of I do a lot of intense
they work with it so I'm trying to like
I'm trying to I'm trying to smooth out a
lot of the memory issues there as well
alright thank you